hi und willkommen zu der Q&A zu Meer
Reportage Sehnsucht nach der Heimat
Portugal ich Portugiesin und Portugiese
als bispel will sie eine von der größte
ständiger ausländische wohnbevölkere
schwitz sind die drittgröchte aber das
ist jetzt wieder mal i der Kommentar me
vor Auge geführt Word es gibt noch ganz
viel andere Nationalitäten wo de schwi
sind und sich genau gich fühlen so dir
Gefühl vor heimw z.B h z.B Isra Schrit
mein Herz immer bei der Familie in
Ägypten da ich in der Schweiz arbeite
fühle ich mich mehr integriert aber die
Idee zurück zu Ägypten zu kehren kommt
immer wieder in Kopf Gabriel schribt
bakalao ist zwar ein Gericht aus
Portugal aber kommt nicht aus Portugal
das sollte man wissen also l Wikipedia
ist es Gericht Portugal und brasiliia da
gebe dir zwar recht aber Portugal STT
auch der bidroid schribt hey Liv red
doch romanisch mit den das ist doch fast
giche ihr m feststellen nein es ist n
gich also ich verstand wenn es gut kommt
höchstens jedes 15 Wort also eiglich
keine Chance es ist schon so wenn man so
sprachen lest den got einfach will man
sich so kann ein Bit Z rechnen was das
könnte bed Wörter viicht ähnlich
Herkunft und dann kann man so B zmer s
philosophier aber wirklich Verst kein
Chance also und sie aber auch nicht das
muss man s aber interessant dass das mit
dem Romanis aufk das eigentlich der
ursprüngliche Grund wieso die Reportage
W machen mit der Portugiesin und
Portugiese ist sie will ich in
grabündwachsen bin und in grabünder
Leben relativ viele Portugiesin und
Portugieser und interessanter wie lernen
die viel besser romanisch als Deutsch
also z.B Oberengadin reden alle in der
Schule der Primarschule romanisch und es
ist viel einfacher für Sie zum romanisch
lernen als Deutsch will hat Sprache doch
ähnlich sind Schau Grund wie so zwei
Drittel von allen Portugiesin und
portugies der schwitz in der westchwitz
leend will auch einfach zum Französisch
lernen alles latinische Sprache und man
liest ab und so mal ein Artikel dass
Portugiesin und Portugieser ab drter vom
romanisch sind dank inner ist wirklich
so gibt viel mehr Kinder wo wieder
romanisch lernen in der Schul wir sind
natürlich froh jeder und jede wo
romanisch redet und das ab Ruch im
Alltag sind wir froh und es ist auch für
die portugiesische Gemeinschaft ein
Vorteil sich zu integrieren wenn sie ja
sprach können wir romanisch der Lukas
schribt wir hätten Schwizer
portugiesische Pass kriegt er referiert
sich da auf der Robert Ledergerber wo
GLB 40 Jahre über 30 Jahre auf Fall mit
Seer Frau aus Portugal verhürot ist und
dann ist es so du kannst der
portugiesische paskrieger durch
Abstammung durch Heirat und durch
Einbürgerung durch Investition also wenn
man Geld in Portugal investiert oder
Einbürgerung durch längeren Aufenthalt
und der Robert fallt in Kategorie durch
Heirat und übrigens ist auch so
umgekehrt also damals wo s no Kyot h hät
Aurora
s die Frau automatisch der schwizerische
Pass kegt Hag ist so du kriegst Pass
auchch h aber nicht einfach so und
direkt man muss so und so lang K sie und
se beber bis man den wirklich schwizp
kriegt als
wo ein schwizerin oder Schwizer h und
spannende Schau zum Thema Pass vi
Portugiesin und Portugieser Pass obwohl
jahrzehang de Schwiz
le Grab vor knapp
wohnerin und iwohner nur 400 ein Pass
bereit innerhalb von letzte 10 Jahr also
2006 bis 201 das zeigt einfach wie viel
wie wenig Interesse best für ein
schwizerische Pass und das hab gefragt W
Reportage wieso wieso h nicht Kost frag
wenn das also Aufwand zum sich so Pass
Sorg und zweitens ist Hal auch sie sag e
C bewigung ich brauch nicht unbedingt
ein Pass das einzige kann machen ist
abstimmen und Wähler aber zum Schaffer
zum sich Geschäft aufbauen BU ich
eigentlich gar nicht der schwizerp der
MEL schribt das K se rechts ü aber ich
find irgendwie schwach dass alle liber
in Portugal le würden dass S der Schwiz
in den Betrag gön keine hindert nur Geld
da blieber aber sich über alles
beschweren und S ah Portugal ist viel
besser das ist schwach also ich glaub
dur falscheruck KT alle Portugiesin und
Portugiese wo in der Reportage und viele
W ja mal telefoniert hab oder so h seit
e mind vi wegen Geld aber bliber s
willst System so gut ist bildigsystem
Gesundheitssystem alle verwaltigge das
funktioniert einfach viel besser als in
Portugal dun und se so Schwiz Schätzer
und leberkär auf die Art aber ich glaub
einfachim Gefühl ich nie weggegangen
also ich glaube die wenigste s Schwiz
ist schlecht der Paul schribt was ich
jedoch nicht verstehen kann ist warum
die Medien Migrantinnen und Migranten
AusländerInnen Ausländer immer in
bestimmten Berufsgruppen darstellen ohne
über ETH Professorinnen und so wier und
so fort und andere akademische Berufe zu
berichten das erzeugt ein verzerrtes und
sogar leicht abwertendes Bild von
Ausländerinnen Ausländer es ist wichtig
ein realistisches und vielschichtiges
Bild von Menschen und mit
Migrationshintergrund zu zeichnen also
ich kann Kritik nicht geldter das S
nicht das vielschichtigs Bild von
Menschen mit migrationshgrund also jetzt
portugies und Portugiese zeigt hab
ehrlichit an z.B dais 2016 im
Gastgewerbe sind 17000 Portugieser und
Portugiesen im mit Aufenthalts und
Niederlassungsbewilligung tätig es ist
die größte nationalitäengruppe im
Sektor also ich finde es W eher verzert
gie wenn ich nicht l aufen Bau und im
gasterb zeigt hätte und ich hab ja
bewusst nicht nur Sie zeagt Sara
z.B sie ist Leiterin von teilig in der
Firma und Antonio hät sich ja eigene
Firma gründet also die Kritik kann ich
mir nicht ganz Gel dass sie nicht das
vielschichtiges Bild Zeichn in der
Reportage gut der noch zum Schluss ein
schöner kommentar von der Trisha mit
italienischer wurzler eine meiner Söhne
hat mit ca 5 Jahren auf ein blattpier
ein Schweizer Kreuz gezeichnet und
dieses dann mit den Landesfarben von
Italien also rotwies grün ausgemalt das
hat mir deutlich vor Augen geführt wie
sehr gleichzeitig zwei Herzen in einer
Brust schlagen konnten ja das ist glaub
auch das so wie der Reportage ist das
ist von der q& danke viel mal für alle
die Kommentar apropos Auswanderer
blieber oder g das ist sch immer wieder
Thema beü da auf dem Youtube Account von
SRF do und am 5 Januar got's wieder los
mit der neue Staffel von U undav
begleiten l auswanderend aus der Schwiz
das got auf Florida auf Mallorca und auf
Island also schön abonniereen der
Account wir sehen un beim nächsten Mal
wieder